The following is a conversation
with Arielle Vinnie Alice.
He's a senior research
scientist at Google deep mind,
and before that he was a Google
brain and Berkeley. Okay.
His research has been
cited over 39,000 times.
He's truly one of the most brilliant
and impactful minds in the field of deep
learning. He's behind some of the
biggest papers and ideas and AI,
including sequence to sequence learning,
audio generation, image captioning,
neural machine translation,
and of course reinforcement learning.
He's a lead researcher of the Alpha
Star Project, creating an agent,
the defeated a top professional
at the game of starcraft.
This conversation is part of the
artificial intelligence podcasts.
If you enjoy it, subscribe
on Youtube, iTunes,
or simply connect with me on
Twitter at Lex Freedman, spelledF ,
r I, d. And now here's my conversation,
Arielle Minneapolis,
you spearheaded the deepmind team behind
Alpha Star that recently beat a top
professional players,
starcraft,
so you have an incredible wealth of
work and deep learning and a bunch of
fields. But let's talk about
starcraft first. Let's go
back to the very beginning,
even before Alpha Star, before deep
mine, before deep learning first,
what came first for you?
A love for programming or
a love for video games?
I think for me it definitely came first.
The drive to play video games.
I really liked computers.
I do and really coats much.
But what I would do is I would just mess
with the computer, break it and fix it.
That was the level of skills, I guess
that again, in my very early days,
I mean when I was 10 or 11 and then I,
I really got into video games,
especially starcraft,
actually the first version,
I spent most of my time just playing
kind of pseudo professionally as
professionally as you could
play back in 98 in Europe,
which was not very main scene leg
that what's called nowadays e-sports,
right? Of course, in the 90s. So, uh,
how'd you get into starcraft?
What, what was your favorite race?
How do you develop, how did
you develop your skill? What,
what was your strategy,
all that kind of thing.
So as a player I tended to
try to play not many games,
not to kind of disclose the
strategies that I kind of developed.
And I like to play random,
actually not in competitions but just to,
I think in starcraft there's,
well there's three main races and I
found it very useful to play with all of
them.
Um,
so I would choose random many times even
sometimes in tournaments to gain skill
on the three races because it's
not how you play against someone,
but also if you understand
the race because you played,
you also understand what's annoying,
what then when you're on the other side,
what to do to annoy that person to try
to gain advantages here and there and so
on. So I actually played random, I
must say in terms of favorite race,
I really liked [inaudible].
Um,
I was probably best at circ and that's
probably what I tend to use towards the
end of my career before
starting university. So
let's step back a little bit.
Could you try to describe starcraft two
people that may never have played video
games, especially the massively
online variety like starcraft.
Starcraft is a real time strategy game.
And the way to think about starcraft,
perhaps if you understand the beat chess,
is that there are,
there's a board which is called
mapper or, or like, yeah,
like the mob where people
play against each other.
There's obviously many ways you can play,
but the most interesting one is the one
versus one set up where you just play
against someone, someone else or even the
built in Ai, right? The laser put, uh,
a system that can play the game reasonably
well if you don't know how to play.
And then in this board you have again,
pieces like in chess,
but these pieces are not there initially.
Like they are in chess.
You actually need to decide to gather
resources to decide which pieces to build.
So in a way you starting almost with no
pieces, you start gathering resources.
In starcraft, there's minerals
and gas that you can gather.
And then you must decide how much
do you want to focus, for instance,
on gathering more resources or
starting to build units or pieces.
And then once you have enough
pieces or maybe like attack,
um,
you a a good attack composition,
then you go and attack
the other side of the map.
And now the other main difference with
Chaz is that you don't see the other side
of the map. So you're not
seeing the moves of the enemy.
It's what we call partially observable.
So as a result that you must not only
decide trading of economy versus building
your own units,
but you also must decide whether you
want to scout to gather information. Um,
but also by scouting you might be giving
away some information that you might be
hiding from the enemy. So there's a
lot of complex decision making, um,
all in real time.
There's also unlike chess,
this is not a turn based game.
You play basically all
the time continuously.
And thus some skill in terms of speed
and accuracy of clicking is also very
important.
And people that train for these really
play this game at at an amazing skill
level. I've seen many times, these
are new, if you can witness these,
life is really, really impressive. Um,
so in a way it's kind of a chess where
you then see the other side of the board.
You were building your own pieces and
you'll also need to gather resources to
basically get some money to build other
buildings, pieces, technology and so on.
From the perspective of the human player.
The difference between that
and chess or maybe that and uh,
a game like turn based strategy,
like here's a mighty magic is that there's
an anxiety because you have to make
these decisions really quickly.
And if you are not actually
aware of what decisions work it,
it's a very stressful,
balanced.
The of everything you described
is actually quite stressful,
difficult to balance for
a amateur human player.
I don't know if it gets easier
at the professional level,
like if they're fully aware
of what they have to do.
But at the amateur level there's this
anxiety, oh crap, I'm being attacked.
Oh crap. I have to uh, build up
resources. Oh, I have to probably expand.
And all these,
the time,
the a real time strategy aspect is
really stressful and computation.
I'm sure difficult. We'll
get into it. But, uh,
for me
battlenet s so starcraft was
released in [inaudible] 98,
20 years ago. It was
just hard to believe. Uh,
and a blizzard battlenet
with a Diablo in 96 came out.
And to me it might be
a narrow perspective,
but it changed online gaming and
perhaps society forever. Yeah.
But I may have made way too narrow
viewpoint. But from your perspective,
uh, can you talk about the history
of gaming over the past 20 years?
Is this how transformational,
how important is this line of games?
Right. So I think I kind of
was an active gamer. Wiles.
These was developing the
Internet, um, online gaming.
So for me that the way it came was I
played other games strategy related,
I played a bit of common and conquer.
And then I played Warcraft two,
which is from blizzard.
But at the time I didn't know,
I didn't understand about what bleeds
or was or anything work off to was just
the game, which is, which was actually
very similar to start in many ways.
It's also real time strategy game
where there's orks and humans.
So there's only two racist. But it
was offline and it was offline, right?
So I remember a friend of mine
came to to school say, oh,
there's this new cool game called
starcraft. And I just said, oh,
this sounds like just a copy of Warcraft
two, um, until I kind of installed it.
And at the time, um, I am from Spain,
so we didn't have intern like very
good internet. Right? So there was,
for us a starcraft became first kind of
an offline experience where you kind of
start to play these missions,
right?
You play against some sort
of scripted things. The,
to double up the story of the
characters in the game. Um,
and then later on I started playing
against the beauty in AI, um,
and I thought it was
impossible to defeat it.
Then eventually you defeat one and you
can actually bring in seven built in the
eyes. At the same time,
we also felt impossible,
but actually it's not that hard
to beat seven [inaudible] at once.
So once we achieve that also we
discovered that we could play,
um, as I said, Internet wasn't that great,
but we could play with the land right on,
like basically against each other
if we were in the same okay.
Plays because you could just connect
machines with like cables, right? Um,
so we started playing in land
mode and against, you know,
as a group of friends and it was really,
really like much more entertaining
than playing against the ice.
And later on as Internet was starting
to double up and being a bit faster and
more reliable, then it's when I
started experiencing battlenet,
which is these amazing universe,
not only because of the fact that
you can play the game against anyway,
anyone in the world,
but you can also get to no more
people you just get exposed to now,
like these vast variety of, it's kind
of a bit of when the chats came about,
right? There was a chat system,
you could play against people,
but you could also chat with people not
only about Steiger, but about anything.
And that became a way of life
for kind of two years. Um, and,
and obviously they need became like kind
of exploded in mean that I started to
play more seriously going to
tournaments and so on, so forth.
Do you have a sense and a
societal sociological level,
what's this whole part of society that
many of us are not aware of and it's a
huge part of society, which
is gamers. I mean I'm,
every time I come across that
in youtube or streaming sites,
I mean this is the huge number
of people play games religiously.
Do you have a sense of those folks,
especially now that you've returned to
that realm a little bit and the Ai side?
Yeah,
so in fact I even after stock or if
I actually played world of Warcraft,
which is the main sort of online walls
on presence that you get to interact with
lots of people. So I played
that for a little bit. It was,
to me it was a bit less stressful than
starcraft because winning was kind of a
given. You just put in this world
and you can always complete missions.
But I think it was actually the social
aspect of specialty starcraft first.
And then games like world of
Warcraft really shaped me in,
in a very interesting way because you are,
you get to experience is just people you
wouldn't usually interact with, right?
So even nowadays,
I still have many Facebook friends from
the area where I played online and their
ways of thinkings, even
political. Um, they just don't,
we don't live in it like we don't
interact in the, in the real world,
but we were connected by basically fiber.
And that way I actually get to
understand a bit better, um,
that we live in a diverse world.
And these were just connections that
were made by, because, you know,
I happened to go in a
city in a beautiful city,
a as a priest and I met these,
you know,
these warrior and we became friends and
then we start like playing together.
Right? So I think it's, it's,
it's transformative and more and more
and more people are more aware of it.
I mean, it's, it's becoming quite
mainstream. But back in the day,
as you were saying,
in 2000 2005 even,
it was very still very
strange thing to do,
especially in Europe. I think there
were exceptions like Korea for instance,
it was amazing that that,
that everything happened so
early in terms of cyber cafes,
like it's if you go to
sell it gets a CT that um,
back into the starcraft was kind of,
you could be a celebrity by
playing starcraft, but this
was like 99, 2000, right?
It's not like recently.
So, um, yeah, it's quite,
it's quite the interesting too
to look back and, and yeah,
I think it's changing
society the same way.
Of course like technology and social
networks and so on are also transforming
things. And a quick tangent, let me ask,
you're also one of the most productive
people in your particular chosen a
passion and path in life.
Uh,
and yet you're also appreciate
and enjoy video games.
Do you think it's possible to do,
uh,
to enjoy video games and moderation?
Someone told me that you could
choose two out of three. Um,
when I was playing video games, you
could choose having a girlfriend, um,
playing video games or studying.
Yeah.
And I think for the most
part it was relatively true.
These things do take time.
Uh, games like stock.
If you take the game pretty
seriously and you want to study it,
then you obviously we'll
dedicate more time to it.
And I definitely took gaming and
obviously studying very seriously. I,
I, I love learning
science and et Cetera. Um,
so to me, especially when I
started university Undergrad,
I kind of step off starcraft. I
actually fully stopped playing. Um,
and then we'll have worker
of was a bit more casual.
You could just connect online. And I mean,
it was, it was fun. Um, but I, as I said,
that was not as much time investment
as it was for and starcraft.
Okay.
So let's get into Alpha Star.
What are the a year behind the team?
Uh,
so deep mine has been working on starcraft
and released a bunch of cool open
source agents and so on past few years,
but Alpha Star really is the moment where,
uh,
the first time you'd beat
a world class player.
So what are the parameters
of the challenge in the
way that Alpha Star took it
on and how did you and David and the
rest of the deepmind team get into it?
Consider the, you can even beat the
bus in the world or top players.
I think it all started in back in 2015.
Um,
actually I'm lying.
I think it was 2014 when the mine was
acquired by Google and I at the time was
at Google brain, which is in, it was in
California, is still in California. Uh,
we had the summit where we
got together the two groups.
So Google brain and Google deepmind got
together and we gave a series of talks
and given that they were doing deep
reinforcement learning for games,
I decided to bring up part of my past.
Um, we, Jay had developed at Berkeley,
like these things, which we call Berkeley
over mind, which is really just a,
a starcraft one Bot,
right?
So I talked about that and I remember
that means just came to me and said, well,
maybe not now. It's, it's
perhaps a bit too early,
but you should just come to the
mind and do these again. Uh,
with deep reinforcement learning.
Right?
And at the time it sounded very science
fiction for, for several reasons.
Uh, but then in 2016, when I actually
moved to London and joined the mine,
I'm transferring from brain.
It became apparent that because
of the Alphago moment, um,
and kind of bleeds or reaching
out to us to say, wait,
do you want the next challenge? And also
me being full time at deep. So sort of,
kind of all these came
together and then I was,
I went to Irvine in California to the
blizzard headquarters to just chat with
them and try to explain how would
it all work before you do anything.
And the approach has always been
about the learning perspective,
right? So, um, in, in Berkeley we
did a lot of rule based, you know,
conditioning and if you have more
than three units then go attack.
And if the other has more units than me,
I retreat and so on and so forth.
And of course the point of debris
enforcement learning, deep learning,
machine learning in general is that
all these should be learned behavior.
So that kind of was the DNA of the project
since its inception in 2016 where we
just didn't even have an environment
to work with. And so this,
that's how it all started really.
So if you go back to that conversation
with Dennis, or even in your own head,
how far away did you, cause that's,
we're talking about Atari Games.
We're talking about go,
which is kind of,
if you're honest about a really
far away from starcraft in, in, uh,
well now that you've beaten it, maybe you
could say as close, but, uh, it's much,
it seems like starcraft is way harder
than go philosophically in mathematically
speaking. Uh, so how far away
did, did you think you were?
Do you think it's 1,019 and 18? You
could be doing as well as you have? Yeah.
When I, when I kind of thought about,
okay, I'm going to dedicate, you know,
a lot of my time and focus on these
and obviously I do a lot of different
research in deep learning.
So spending time on it.
I mean I really had to kind of think
there's going to be something good
happening out of this.
Um, so really I thought,
well these sounds impossible
and it probably is impossible
to do the full thing,
like the all like the full game,
um, where you play one versus one.
Um, and it's only a neural network playing
and so on. Um, so it really felt like,
I just didn't even think it was possible.
But on the other hand,
I could see some stepping stones
like towards that goal. Um,
clearly you could define sub problems in
starcraft and sort of dissected a beat
and say, okay, here is a part of
the game. Here is another part. Um,
and also obviously the fact that,
so this was really also critical to me,
the fact that we could
access human replace, right?
So pleaser was very kind and in fact
they open source these for the whole
community where you can just go and
it's not every single stock of game ever
played,
but it's a lot of them you can just go
and download and everyday they will you,
you can just query a data set and say,
well give me all the games
that were played today.
And given my kind of experience with
language and sequences and supervised
learning, I thought, well that's
definitely going to be very helpful.
And something quite unique now because
ever before we had such a large data set
of replays of people playing the game
at this scale of such a complex video
game. Right? So that to me
was a precious resource.
And as soon as I knew that [inaudible]
was able to kind of give these to the
community, I started to feel positive
about something [inaudible] happening.
But, but I also thought the full
thing, like really no rules, no,
no single line of code that tries to say,
well,
I mean if you see these units
builds the detector, all these,
I'm not having any of these as
specializations seemed really, really,
really difficult to me intuitively.
I do also like that blizzard
was teasing or even trolling
meal, a sort of almost uh, yeah,
pulling you in into this
really difficult challenge.
Did they have any aware what's,
what's the interest from the perspective
of blizzard except just curiosity?
Yeah, I think believes or has
really understood and really bring,
bring forward this competitiveness
of east ports in the Games.
The starcraft really kind of sparked a
lot of like something that almost was
never seen, especially as I
was saying, eat back in Korea.
So they just probably thought,
wow,
this is such a pure one versus one
setup that it will be great to see, um,
if something that can play Atari or
go and then later on chess could,
could even tackle these kind of
complex real time strategy game. Right.
So for them,
they wanted to see first obviously
whether it was possible, if,
if, if the game they created was in
a way it's solvable to some extent.
And I think on the other hand,
they also are a pretty modern
company that innovates a lot.
So just starting to understand AI for
them to how to bring AI into games is not,
is not AI for games,
but games for AI, right?
I mean both ways I think can work.
And you up,
we obviously at the man use games
for AI, right, to drive AI progress,
but pleaser might actually be able to
do and many other companies to start to
understand and do the opposite.
So I think that is also something they
can get out of these. And they definitely,
we have brainstorm a lot
about about these, right.
But one of the interesting things to
me about starcraft and Diablo and these
games that blizzard is created is the
task of balancing classes, for example,
a sort of making the game
fair from the starting point.
And then let's skill determine
the outcome. Uh, is there, uh,
I mean, can you first comment there's
three races are Protoss and Taryn,
I don't know if I've ever said that out
loud. Is that how you pronounce it, Taryn?
Yeah. Uh, yeah.
I don't think I've ever sold in person
interacted with anybody about starcraft.
It's funny.
Uh,
so they seem to be pretty balanced.
I wonder if the AI,
the work that you're doing with Alpha
Star would help balance them even further.
Is that something you think about?
Is that something that blizzard
is thinking about? Right. So,
so balancing when you add a new need or
a new spell type is obviously possible
given that you can always
train or retrain at scale.
Some agent that might start
using that in unintended ways.
But I think actually if you understand
how starcraft has kind of coy evolve with
players in a way,
I think it's actually very cool the ways
that many of the things and strategies
that people came up with,
right? So I think it's,
we've seen it over and over in starcraft
that bleeds or comes up with maybe a
new unit and then some players get
creative and do something kind of
unintentional or something that blizzard
designers that just simply didn't test
or think about.
And then after that becomes kind of
mainstream in the community bleeds or
patches the gang. And then they kind
of, maybe we can that strategy or,
or make it actually more
interesting but a bit more balanced.
So these kind of continual talk
between players and research,
this is kind of what has defined them
actually in actually most games I the
stacker but also in world of
Warcraft they would do that.
There are several classes and it
would be not good that everyone plays
absolutely the same raise
or and so on. Right. So, um,
I think they do care
about balancing of course.
And they do a fair amount of testing,
but it's also beautiful to,
to also see how players get
creative anyways. And I mean,
whether I can be more creative at this
point. I don't think so. Right. I mean,
it's just sometimes some
things are so amazing happens.
Like I remember back in the days like
you have these drop ships that could drop
the rivers and that was actually not
thought about that you could drop these
unit that has these what's called splash
damage that would basically eliminate
all the enemies workers at once.
No one thought that you could actually
put them in really early game,
do that kind of damaged and then you know,
things changing the game.
But I don't know,
I think there's,
it's quite an amazing exploration
process from both sides.
Players and blizzard alike.
Well it's a, it's almost
like a reinforcement learning
exploration, but any,
the scale of humans that play
that play blizzard games is almost
on the scale of a large scale,
deep mind RL experiment. I mean,
if you look at the numbers, it's,
I mean you're talking about,
I don't know how many games,
but hundreds of thousands
of games. Probably a month.
Yeah. I mean, so you could,
it's almost the same
as running a RL agents.
What aspect of the problem of starcraft
he thinks the hardest. Does it the,
like you said,
the imperfect information,
is it the fact they have
to do long term planning?
Is it the realtime aspects we
have to Duke stuff really quickly?
Is it the fact that a large
action space so you can do so
many possible things?
Or is it the, you know,
in the game theoretic sense there is no
national Glybera at least you don't know
what the optimal strategy
is because there's way too
many options, right? What's,
is there something that stands
out as just like the hardest,
the most annoying thing?
So when we sort of looked at the problem
and start to define the parameters of
it, what are the observations, what are
the actions? Um, it became very apparent.
Um, that's, you know, the,
the very first barrier that one would
hit in starcraft would be because of the
action space being so large and as not
being able to search like you could in,
in chess or go, even though
the search space is vast. Um,
the main problem that we identified
was that of exploration. Right?
So without any sort of human
knowledge or human prior.
If you think about starcraft and you
know how deep reinforcement learning
algorithm works work,
which is essentially by issuing random
actions and hoping that they will get
some wins sometimes so they could learn.
So if you think of the of the
action space in starcraft,
almost anything you can do in the early
game is bad because any action involves
taking workers which are
mining minerals for free.
That's something that the game does
automatically sends them to mind and you
would immediately just take them
out of mining and send them around.
So just thinking how,
how is it going to be possible to,
to get to understand that these concepts,
but but even more like expanding, right?
There's,
there's these buildings you can place
in other locations in the map to gather
more resources,
but the location of the building is
important and you have to select a worker,
send it, walking to that
location, build the building,
wait for the building to be built,
and then boot extra workers there so they
start mining that just that feels like
impossible.
If you just randomly click to produce
that state desirable state that then you
could hope to learn from because
eventually that may yield to an extra win.
Right?
So for me,
the exploration problem and due to the
action space and the fact that there's
not really turns,
there's so many turns because the game
essentially teaks at 22 times per second
if you, I mean that's how they
could, is criticize sort of time.
Obviously you always have to
discreet ice time. There's no,
no such thing as real time,
but it's really a lot of time steps
of things that could go wrong.
And that definitely felt
Apriori like the hardest. Um,
you mentioned many good ones. I
think partial observability. Um,
the fact that there is no perfect strategy
because of the Paschal observability
those are very interesting problems.
We start seeing more and more now in
terms of us, we solved the previous ones.
But the core problem to me was,
uh,
exploration and solving it has been
basically kind of the focus and how we saw
the first breakthroughs.
So exploration in a,
in a multi hierarchical way.
So like
22 times a second.
Exploration has a very different meaning
than it does in terms of should I
gather resources early or
should I wait or so on.
And so how do you solve the long term?
Let's talk about the internals
of Alpha Stein. So first of all,
how do you represent the state
of the game, uh, as an input?
How do you then do the longterm sequence
modeling? How do you build a policy?
What, what's the, what's the
architecture like? So out of a star has
obviously several components,
but everything passes through
what we call the policy,
which is a neural network.
And that's kind of the beauty of it there
is I could just now give you a neural
network and some weights and if you
fed the right observations and you
understood the actions the same way we do,
you would have basically
the agent playing the game.
There is absolutely nothing else needed
other than those weights that were
trained.
Now the first step is observing the
game and we've experimented with a few
alternatives.
The one that we currently use mixes,
both spacial sort of images that you
would process from the game that is the
zoomed out version of the,
of the map and also assume the inversion
of the camera or the screen as we call
it,
but also we give to the agent the least
of units that it sees more of as a set
of objects that it can operate on that
is not necessarily required to use it.
And we have versions of the game that
play well without these set vision.
That is not like how
humans perceive the game,
but it certainly helps a lot because it's
a very natural way to encode the game
is by just looking at all the
unions that there are there.
They have properties like
health was Aetion type of unit,
whether it's my unit or the enemies.
And that's sort of is kind of the,
the summary of,
of the state of, of the, of the game.
Not that least of units or set of
units that you see all the time.
Well that's pretty close to the way humans
see the game. Why do you say it's not?
Isn't that a, you're saying the
exactness of it is not only to humans,
the exactness of it is
perhaps not the problem.
I guess maybe the problem if you look
at it from how actually humans play the
game is that they play with a mouse and
a keyboard and a screen and they don't
see sort of a structured object
with all the units, what they see,
what they see on the
screen. Right? Yeah. So
you remember that there's
a siren interrupt.
There's a plot that he showed with
camera based. We do exactly that. Right?
Move around. And that seems to
converge to similar performance.
Yeah.
I think that's what we're
kind of experimenting with
what's necessary or not,
but using the set.
So,
so actually if you look at research in
computer region where it makes a lot of
sense to treat images
as two dimensional race,
there is actually a very nice
paper from Facebook, I think. Um,
I forgot who the authors are, but I think
it's, um, part of gaming skills group.
And what they do is they take an image
which is that these two dimensional
signal and they actually take pixel by
Pixel and scramble the image as if it was
just a least of pixels.
And crucially they encode the position
of the pixels with the x y coordinates.
And this is just kind
of a new architecture,
which we incidentally also using
stacked graph called the transformer,
which is a very popular
paper from last year,
which yielded very nice
result in machine translation.
And if you actually believe in this kind
of, oh it's actually a set of pixels,
as long as you encode x
why it's okay then you,
you could argue that the list of units
that we see is precisely that because we
have each unit as a kind of pixel,
if you will, and then their x,
y coordinates. So in that
perspective we, without knowing it,
we use the same architecture that was
shown to work very well on Pascal and
image net and so on. So the interesting
thing here is putting it in that way,
it starts to move a tours the way
usually work with language. So what,
and especially with your expertise
and uh, uh, work in language,
it seems like there's echoes of a lot of,
um,
the way you would work with
natural language in the
way you've approached Alpha
Star right there.
What's,
does that help with the longterm sequenced
modeling there somehow? Exactly. So,
so now that we understand what an
observation for a given time step is, uh,
we need to move on to say,
well,
there's going to be a sequence of
such observations and an agent.
We'll need to given all that he'd seen
not only the current time step but all
that he'd seen.
Why?
Because there is partial observability
we must remember whether we saw a worker
going somewhere for instance,
right?
Because then there might be an
expansion on the top right of the map.
So given that what you
must then think about this,
there is the problem of
given all the observations,
you have to predict the next action.
And not only given all the observations,
but given all the observations and given
all the actions you've taken predict
the next action.
And that sounds exactly like
machine translation where,
and that's exactly how
kind of I saw the problem,
especially when you are given supervised
data or replace from humans because the
problem is exactly the same.
You're translating essentially a prefix
of observations and actions onto what's
going to happen next,
which is exactly how you would train
a model to translate or to generate
language as well. Right? Do
you have a certain prefix?
You must remember everything that comes
in the past because otherwise you might
start having non-coherent text
and the same architectures. Um,
we using LSTM and transformers to operate
on across time to kind of integrate.
All that's happened in the past,
those architectures that work so well
in translation or language malady are
exactly the same than what the agent is
using to issue actions in the game and
the way we train it. Moreover
for imitation, which is
step one of Alpha stories,
take all the human experience
and try to imitate it.
Match like you try to imitate
translators that translated many pairs of
sentences from French to English.
Say that sort of principle
applies exactly the same.
It's almost the same code,
except that instead of words,
you have a slightly more
complicated objects,
which are the observations and the
actions are also a bit more complicated.
That Dan award is there a
self play component then too.
So once you run out of
imitation, right? So,
so indeed you can bootstrap
from human replace,
but then the agents you get are actually
not as good as the humans you imitated.
Right? So how do we imitate, well,
we take humans from 3000 MMR
and hire 3000 and memories.
Just a metric of human skill and 3000
and [inaudible] might be like 50%
percentile, right? So it's just
Kevin average human, what's the,
so maybe quick pause and Mars.
A ranking scale.
The matchmaking rating for players.
So it's threes.
I remember there's like a master
and a grand master was 3000.
So 3000 is pretty bad. Um, I
think it's kind of goals level.
It just sounds really good
relative to chess, I think.
Oh yeah, yeah. No, the, the,
the ratings. The best thing though.
Water at 7,000. [inaudible] um, so 3008,
we'd like Eloy. Indeed. Right,
so (300) 030-0500 just allows us to not
feel there are a lot of the data so we
like to have a lot of data and deep
learning as as you probably know,
so we take these kind of 3,500 and above
but then we do a very interesting trick
which is we tell the neural network
what level they are imitating so we say
these replay you are going to try to
imitate to predict the next action for all
the actions that you're going
to see is a 4,000 MMR replay.
These one is a 6,000 MMR we play and
what what's cool about these is then we
take these policy that is being trained
from human and then we can ask it to
play like a 3000 Mr player
by setting a bit saying,
well okay play like a 3000 MMR player
or play like a 6,000 MMR player and you
actually see how the policy behaves
differently. It gets worse. The economy.
If you play like a gold level player,
it does less actions per minute,
which is the number of clicks or number
of actions that you will issue in the
whole minutes and it's very
interesting to see that.
It kind of imitates the
skill level quite well,
but if we ask it to play
like a 6,000 MMR player,
we tested of course these
policies to see how well they do.
They actually beat all the builtin
ais that bleeds or put in the game,
but they're nowhere near
6,000 MMR players. Right?
They might be maybe around
gold level platinum perhaps.
So there's still a lot of work to be
done for the policy to truly understand
what it means to win. So
far we only ask them, okay,
here is the screen and that's what's
happened on the game until this point.
What would the next action be if we ask,
you know, we ask a pro to now say, oh,
you're going to click
here or here or there.
And the point is experiencing,
experiencing wins and losses is very
important to then start to refine a,
otherwise the policy can get loose, can,
can just go off policy as we call it.
That's so interesting that you can at
least hope eventually to be able to
control a policy,
uh,
approximately to be at a some MMR
level as that's so interesting.
Especially given that you have ground
truth for a lot of these cases. Right. Uh,
can I ask you a personal question?
Sure. Uh, what's your MMR? Well,
I haven't played stacker off too,
so I am unranked Oh,
says the kind of lowest league. Okay.
So I used to play starcraft one,
the first one, but you haven't
seriously playing doctor I've talked to.
So the best player we have at
deep mind is about 5,000 MMR.
We gs hi masters is not
at grand master level. Um,
grandmaster level would be the top 200
players in a certain region like Europe
or America or Asia.
Um,
but for me it's would be hard to
say I am very bad at the game.
I actually played Alphas therapy
too late and he'd beat me.
I remember the whole team was, oh,
Oreo, you should play. And I was, oh,
it looks like it's not so good yet.
And then I remember I,
I kind of got busy and waited an extra
week and I played on it really lead me
very badly. I mean, how did that feel? Is
that, isn't that an amazing feeling lens?
Amazing.
Yeah.
I mean obviously I tried my best
and I tried to also impress my,
cause I actually played the first game,
so I'm still pretty good
at micro management. Um,
the brummies I just don't
understand starcraft two.
I understand starcraft and when I played
starcraft I probably was consistently
like for, for a couple of
years, stop 32 in Europe. Um,
so I was decent,
but at the time we didn't have these kind
of MMR system as as well established.
So it will be hard to know
what it was back then.
So what's the difference in the interface
between Alpha Star and starcraft and
the human player and starcraft?
Is there any significant differences
between the way they both see the game?
I would say the way they see the game,
there's a few things that are
just very hard to simulate. Um,
the main one perhaps, which is
all be using hindsight, these,
um, what's called cloaked units,
which are invisible units.
So in,
in starcraft you can make some units that
you need to have a particular kind of,
you need to detectives. So
these unions, I am visible.
If you cannot detect them, you cannot
target them. So they would just, you know,
destroy your buildings
or kill your workers.
But despite the fact you
cannot target the unit,
there's a shimmer that as a
human you observe. I mean,
you need to train a little bit,
do you need to pay attention,
but you would see these kind of spacetime
spacetime like distortion and you
wouldn't know. Okay. There are, yeah.
Yeah. There's like a wave thing.
Shimmers tends to storage.
I don't like it.
That's really like the term is
Shimmer, shimmer. So these Shimmer,
um, professional players
actually can see it immediately.
They understand it very well,
but it's still something that requires
certain amount of attention and, and,
and it's kind of a bit annoying to
deal with. Whereas for Alpha Star,
in terms of vision, it's very hard for us
to simulate sort of all, you know, are,
are you looking at these pixels
in the screen and so on. So, um,
the only thing we can do is we, there
is a unit that's invisible over there.
So Alpha Starwood know that immediately.
Um, obviously still obeys the rules.
You cannot attack the, you need, you
must have a detector and so on. But it's,
it's kind of one of the main things
that he just doesn't feel there's,
there's a very proper way. I
mean, you could imagine, oh,
you, you don't have hypers.
Maybe you don't know exactly where it is,
or sometimes you see it,
sometimes you don't. But
it's, it's just really,
really complicated to get it so that
everyone would agree, oh, that's,
that's the best way to simulate
these. Right. You know,
it seems like a perception problem.
It is a perception problem. So,
so the only problem is people are,
you ask her what's the difference
between how humans perceive the game?
I would say they wouldn't be able to tell
a shimmer immediately as it appears on
the screen. Whereas Alpha
starting principal sees it
very sharply, right? It sees,
it sees that the beat turned from zero to
one, meaning there is now a unit there,
although you don't know the unit
or you don't know, you know,
you know that you cannot attack
it and so on. Um, so that from,
from a vision standpoint,
that probably is the one that
is kind of the most obvious one.
Then there are things humans cannot
do perfectly, even professionals,
which is they might miss a detail
or they might have not seen a unit.
And obviously as a computer,
if there's a corner of the screen that
turns green because a unit enters the
field of view that can go
into the memory of the agent,
the LSTM and proceeds there for a while
and for whatever for however long is
relevant. Right. And
in terms of action, uh,
it seems like the rate of actions
from Alpha stars comparative,
it's not slower than professional players
but is there but it's more precise as
what right. So, so that's, that's very,
that's really probably the one that is
causing us more issues for couple of
reasons.
Right.
The first one is starcraft has been an
AI environment for quite a few years. Um,
in fact,
I mean I was participating in the very
first competition back in 2010 and
there's really not been that kind
of a very clear set of rules,
how the actions per minute,
the rate of actions that you can issue
is and as a result of these agents or
blogs that people build in a
kind of almost very cool way.
They do like 20,000,
40,000 actions per minute.
Now now to put this in perspective,
a very good professional human,
my do 300 to 800 actions per minute.
They might not be as precise.
That's why the range is a bit tricky to,
to identify exactly.
I mean 300 actions per minute
precisely is probably realistic. Um,
800 is probably not.
But you see humans doing a lot of actions
because they warm up and they kind of
select things and spam and so on,
just so that when they need,
they have the accuracy.
So we came into this by not having
kind of a standard way to say,
well, how do we measure, um, whether
an agent is at human level or not.
On the other hand,
we had the huge advantage,
which is because we do imitation learning
agents turned out to act like humans
in terms of rate of actions,
even precisions and in precisions
of actions in the supervised policy,
you could see all these,
you could see how agents like
to spam click to move here.
If you played especially the outro,
you wouldn't know what I mean. I mean,
it was just dumb like spam or
movie or Murphy or move here.
You're doing literally like, um,
maybe five actions in two seconds.
But these actions are not bay, meaning
meaningful one would have sufficed.
So on the one hand we start from these
immigration policy that is at the
ballpark of the actions per millions
of humans because it's actually
statistically trying to imitate humans.
So we see these very nicely in the curves
that we showed him, the blog posts,
like there's these actions per minute and
the distribution looks very human like,
um, but then of course as self
play kicks in and that's the buy,
we haven't talked too much yet,
but of course the agent mass
played in itself to improve,
then there's almost no guarantees that
these actions will not become more
precise or even the rate of actions
is going to increase over time. Um,
so what we did,
and this is probably kind of the first
of them that we thought was reasonable,
is we looked at the distribution of
actions for humans for certain windows of
time.
And just to give a perspective,
because I guess I mentioned that some
of these agents that are programmatic,
let's call them, they do 40,000 actions
per minute. Professionals, as I said,
do 300 to 800.
So what we looked at is we look at the
distribution over professional gamers and
we took reasonably high
actions per minute,
but we kind of identify
certain cutoffs after weeds.
Even if the agent wanted to act,
these actions would be dropped.
But the problem is these cutoff
is probably set a bit too high.
And what ends up happening even
though the games and when we as the
professionals and the gamers by by and
large, they feel like it's playing human.
Like, um, there are some
Asians that developed, um,
maybe slightly too high aps,
uh,
which is actions per minute
combined with the position. Um,
which made people sort of start
discussing a very interesting issue,
which is should we limited these,
should we just let it loose and see what
cool things it can come up with? Right.
Interesting. Um, so this is in itself
an extremely interesting question,
but the same way that modeling the
Shimmer will be so difficult modeling.
Absolutely.
All the details about muscles and
precision and tiredness of humans would be
quite difficult. Right? So we really hear
in kind of innovating in the sense of,
okay,
what could be maybe the next iteration
of putting more rules that makes the
agents
more human,
like in terms of restrictions,
putting constraints that more constraints.
Yeah, that's really interesting.
That's really innovative.
So one of the constraints you put on your,
on yourself,
or at least focused in is on the
protests race as far as I understand. Uh,
can you tell me about the
different races and how they, uh,
so protest Taryn and a Zerg, how do
they compare? How do they interact?
Why did you choose protests? Right. Yeah,
it's in the dynamics of the game
scene from a strategic perspective.
So protose um, so in, in stock
or if there are three races, um,
indeed in the demonstration
we saw only the protest race.
So maybe let's start with that.
One.
Practice is kind of the most
technologically advanced race. Um,
it has units that are
expensive but powerful, right?
So in general, you want to kind of
conserve your units, um, as you go attack.
So you want to,
and then you want to utilize
these tactical advantages
of very fancy spells and
so on, so forth. Um, and
at the same time, uh,
there kind of people say like there,
there'll be easier to play perhaps.
Right. But that I actually didn't know.
I mean I just talked to now a lot to
the players that we work with Tlo and
manner and they said, Oh
yeah, protests is actually,
people think is actually one of the
easiest races. So perhaps the easier,
that doesn't mean that it's know
obviously professional players Xcel at the
three races and there's never like a
raise that dominates for debate long time
anyways.
If you look at the top, I don't
know, a hundred in the world,
is there one race that
dominates the lists?
It would be hard to know because it
depends on the regions. I think. Um,
it's pretty equal in terms of distribution
and blizzard once it to be equal.
Right.
They don't want,
they wouldn't want one raise like protest
to not be representative in the top
place. Right. Um, so definitely like
they tried to be like the balance.
Right.
So then maybe the opposite race of
Protos CCIRC Zurich is a raised where you
just kind of expand and take over as
many resources as you can and they have a
very high capacity to regenerate
their units. So if you have an army,
it's not that valuable in terms of losing
the whole army is not a big deal as
Dirk because you can then rebuild it.
And given that you generally
accumulate a huge bank resources, um,
Zurich's typically play by
applying a lot of pressure,
maybe losing the whole army but
then rebuilding it quickly. So, um,
although of course every race,
I mean there's never, um,
I mean they're pretty diverse.
I mean,
there are some units that
are technologically advanced
and they do some very
interesting spells and there's some units
in protests that are less valuable and
you could lose a lot of them and
rebuild them and it wouldn't be a big
deal. All right, so maybe I'm missing out,
maybe I'm going to say some dumb stuff,
but, uh, so summary of strategies.
So first there's collection of a lot of
resources, right? So that's one option.
The other one is explore expanding,
so building other basins.
Then the other is obviously
attack building units and
attacking with those units.
And then, uh, I don't
know what else there is a,
maybe there's the different
timing of attacks,
like do I attack early attack rate?
What are the different strategies that
emerged that you've learned about?
I've read a bunch of people are super
happy that you guys have apparently at
Alpha Pi star apparel is discovered
that it's really good to, uh,
what does it saturate? Oh yeah. Let me
know the line. Yeah, the mineral line is,
yeah. Yeah. And that's a, for
greedy amateur players like myself,
that's always been a good strategy.
You just build up a lot of money and he's
just feels good to just accumulate and
accumulate. Uh, so thank you for
discovering that and validating all of us.
But is there other strategies that you
discovered interesting, a unique to a,
to this game? Yeah. So
if you look at the kind of not
being a starcraft two player,
but of course starcraft,
starcraft two and realtime strategy
games in general are very similar. Um,
I would classify perhaps,
um,
the openings of the game.
They're very important.
And generally I would say
there's two kinds of openings.
One that's standard opening.
That's generally how
players find sort of a,
a balance between risk an economy and
building some units early on so that they
could defend but they're
not to expose basically,
but also expanding quite
quickly. Um, so these,
these would be kind of a standard opening
and within a standard opening then you,
what you do choose generally's what
technology are you aiming towards?
So there's a bit of rock paper,
scissors of you could go for spaceships
or you could go for invisible units or
you could go for either not like massive
units that attack against certain kinds
of units, but they're
weaker hands. Others.
So standard openings themselves
have some choices like rock, paper,
scissors style.
Of course,
if you scout and you're good at
guessing what the opponent is doing,
then you can play in as an advantage.
Because if you know
you're going to play rock,
I mean I'm going to play paper obviously.
So you can imagine that
normal standard games,
Instagram looks like a
continuous rock paper,
scissors game where you guess what the
distribution of rock paper and Caesar is
from the anime and reacting accordingly
to try to beat it or you know,
put the paper out before he kind of
changes his mind from rock to Caesars and
then you would be in a weak position.
So sorry to pause on that. Yeah,
I didn't realize this element
because I know it's true.
Put Poker and I looked at it Broaddus
you're the CEO.
You're also estimating trying to guess
the distributor trying to better but our
estimate the distribution, what the
opponent is likely to be doing. Yeah.
I mean not as a player.
You definitely want to have a belief
state over what's APP on the other side of
the map. Um, and when your
belief state becomes inaccurate,
when you start having that serious doubts,
whether he's going to play something that
you must know, that's when you, Scott,
you want to then gather information,
right?
Is improving the accuracy of the belief
or improving the belief state part of
the loss that you tried to optimize?
Or is it just an a side effect?
It's implicit buttons lists.
You could explicitly model it and it
would be quite good at probably predicting
what's on the other side of the map.
But so far it's all implicit. The law,
there's no, no additional
reward for predicting the enemy.
So there's these standard openings and
then there's what people call it cheese,
which is very interesting.
And Alpha Star sometimes really likes
these kinds of cheese. Um, these cheeses,
what they are is kind
of an online strategy.
You're going to do something sneaky,
you're gonna hide enemies,
hide your own buildings,
close to the enemy base,
or you're going to go for hiding your
technology called buildings so that you do
invisible units and the enemy just cannot
react to the tactic and thus lose the
game. And there's quite a few of
these cheeses and variance of,
of them and they're,
it's where actually the belief
state becomes even more important.
Because if I scout your base and I see
no buildings at all, any human prayer,
know something's up,
they might know,
well you're hiding
something close to my base.
Should I build suddenly a
lot of units to defense?
You'll should I actually block my ramp
with workers so that you cannot come and
destroy my base.
So there's all these is happening and
defending against Jesus is extremely
important.
And in the Alpha Star League,
many agents actually double
up some cheesy strategies.
And in the games we saw
against Tlo and manner,
two out of the 10 agents were actually
doing these kinds of strategies,
which are cheesy strategies.
And then there's a barrier of cheesy
strategy we just called all in.
So an all in strategy is not
perhaps as drastic as, oh,
I'm going to build cannons on your base
and then bring all my workers and try to
just disrupt your base and game over.
Or Gigi, as we say in starcraft,
um, there's these kind of very cool
things that you can align precisely at the
certain time mark.
So for instance,
you can generate exactly 10 unit
composition. That is perfect.
Like five of these type five of these
other type and align the upgrade so that
at four and a half,
let's say you have these 10 units and
the upgrade just finished and at that
point that army is really scary and
unless the enemy really knows what's going
on,
if you push,
you might then have an advantage because
maybe the enemy is doing something more
standard.
It expanded to match it.
It developed too much economy and and
he'd trade off badly against having
defenses and the enemy will lose,
but it's called Arlene because if you
don't win then you're going to lose.
So you see players that do these kinds
of strategies if they don't succeed,
gave me,
is not over.
I mean they still have a base and
they still gathering minerals,
but they will just DJ out of the game
because they know, well game is over.
I gambled and I failed.
So is if we start entering the
game theoretic aspects of the game,
it's really rich and it's really,
that's why it also makes
it quite entertaining to
watch. Even if I don't play,
I still enjoy watching the game.
But the agents are trying to
do these Mosley impressively,
but one element that we improved in self
place creating the Alpha state league
and the Alpha Star League
is not pure self play.
It's trying to create a
different personalities of
agents so that some of them
will become cheese, cheesy agents. Some
of them might become very economical,
very greedy, like getting
all, all the resources,
but then being maybe early
on they going to be weak,
but later on they're
going to be very strong.
And by creating this
personality of agents,
which sometimes it just happens naturally
that you can see kind of an evolution
of agents that given
the previous generation,
they train against all of them and
then they generate kind of the count,
the perfect counter to that
distribution. But these, these agents,
you must have them in the populations
because if you don't have them,
you're not covered against these
things, right? It's kind of you want to,
you want to create all sorts
of the opponents that you
will find in the wild so
you can be exposed to these
cheeses early aggression later,
aggression, more expansions, dropping
units. In your base from the site,
all these things and pure self play
is getting a bit stuck at finding some
subset of these,
but not all of these.
So the Alpha Star League is a way to kind
of do an in of agents that they're all
playing in a league match. Like people
play on Battle Net, right? They play,
you play against someone who does newco
strategy and you immediately, oh my God,
I want to try it,
I want to play again.
And these to me was another critical
part of the, of the, of the problem,
which was can we create a
battle net four agents? Yeah.
That's kind of what the
office star League fascinating
and where they stick to their different
strategies. Yeah. Wow. That's,
that's really, really interesting.
So, but that said, you, uh, uh,
we're fortunate enough or
skilled enough to win five zero.
Uh, and so how hard is it to win? I
mean, that's not the goal. I guess.
I don't know what the goal is.
The goal should be doing majority,
not five zero. But how hard
is it in general to win? Uh,
all matchups I a one one V one.
So that's a very interesting question
because once you see Alpha Star and
superficially you think, well,
okay it one, let's if you,
some of the games like 10 to one,
right,
they'd lost the game that it played with
the camera interface. You might think,
well that's, that's done
right. There's, it's,
it's super human at the game and that's
not really the claim we really can make
actually the claim is we beat a
professional gamer for the first time.
Um, start growth has really been a thing
that has been going on for a few years.
But [inaudible] a moment like this
hasn't not had not occurred before yet,
but are these agents impossible
to beat? Absolutely not. Right?
So that's a bit what's,
you know,
kind of the differences the
agents play at grandmaster level.
They are definitely understand the
game enough to play extremely well. Um,
but are they unbeatable? Do
they play perfect? Um, no,
and actually in starcraft,
because of these sneaky strategies,
it's always possible that you
might take a huge risk sometimes,
but you might get wins right out of these.
So I think that as a domain,
it's still has a lot of opportunities,
not only because of course we want
to learn with less experience.
We would like to, I mean, if I, if I
learned to pray protests, I can play,
turn and learn it much quicker
than Alpha Star Canton. Right?
So there are obvious interesting
research challenges as well,
but even as, as the raw, as
the raw performance goes, um,
really the claim here can be,
we are at the pro level or at,
at grant high grandmaster
level. Um, but obviously, um,
the players also did not
know what to expect, right?
These kind of their prior distribution
was a bit off because they played this
kind of new like alien brain
as they like to say drive.
And that's what makes it
exciting for them. But also,
I think if you look at the games closely,
you see there were
weaknesses in some points.
Maybe Alpha start did not scout or if it
had had invisible units going against,
at certain points it wouldn't have
known and it would have been bad.
So there's still quite a lot of work
to do. Um, but it's really a very,
very exciting moment for us to be seeing.
Wow.
A single neural net on a GPU is actually
playing against these guys who are
amazing. I mean, you have to see
them play in life. They're really,
really amazing players.
Yeah, I'm sure there's,
there's a, there must,
there must be a guy in Poland somewhere
right now training his butt off to make
sure that this never happens
again with Alpha star.
So that's really exciting in terms of
Alpha star having some holes to exploit,
which is great.
And then you build on top of each other
and it feels like starcraft, unlike go,
even if you win, it's still
not there. Still not there.
So
many different dimensions in which
you can explore. So that's really,
really interesting. Do you think
there's a ceiling to Alpha Star?
You've said that it hasn't reached, you
know, it's, this is a big, like what,
let me actually just pause for a second.
How did it feel to,
to come here to this point to,
to beat a top professional player
like that night? I mean, you know,
Olympic athletes have their
gold medal, right? This is
your gold medal sense. Sure.
You're cited a lot. You've published
a lot of procedures, papers, whatever.
But this is like a win.
Uh, how did it feel?
I mean it was, for me
it was unbelievable. Um,
because first the,
we need south me,
it was so exciting.
I mean the,
so looking back to those last
days of 2018 really well,
that's when the games were played. Um,
I'm sure I, I look back at that moment,
I say, oh my God, I want to be
like in a project like that,
it's like I already feel
the nostalgia of like, yeah,
that was huge in terms of the energy
and the team effort that went into it.
And so in that sense, as soon as it
happened, I already knew it was kind of,
I was losing it a little bit.
So it is almost like sad that it happened
and oh my God. But on the other hand,
it also verifies the
approach. Um, but to me also,
there's so many challenges and interesting
aspects of intelligence that even
though we can train a neural network to
play at the level of the best humans,
um, there's still so many challenges.
So for me it's also like, well,
this is really an amazing achievement,
but I already was also thinking
about next steps. I mean, as I said,
these Asians play protest versus protos.
Um,
but they should be able to play a
different race much quicker, right?
So that would be an amazing achievement.
Some people call these metal reinforcement
learning, metal learning and so on,
right? So there's so many
possibilities after that moment,
but the moment he'd solve it
really felt great. Um, it's, I,
we had these bets, so, so I, I'm
kind of a pessimistic in general,
so I kind of send an email
to the team. I said, okay,
let's against deal offers, right?
Like what's going to be the result?
And I really thought we would lose
like five zero. Right? Aye. I,
we had some calibration made
against the 5,000 MMR player. Um,
Dlo was much stronger than that player.
Even if he played protests,
which is his off race. Um, but yeah,
it was not imagined we would wait.
So for me that was just kind
of a test run or something.
And then it really kind of,
he was really surprised and unbelievably,
we went to these,
to these bar to celebrate and,
and Dave thousand me, well wait,
why don't we invite someone who is
a thousand MMR stronger in protests,
like an actual protest player like
that. He ended up being manner. Right.
And you know, we had some drinks and I
said, sure, why not? But then I thought,
well that's really going
to be impossible to beat.
I mean even because it is so much,
I had a thousand MMR is really
like 99% probability that Manna,
we'd beat Tlo as protest versus protests.
Right.
So we did that and to me the second,
the second game was much more important.
Even though a lot of uncertainty
kind of disappeared after,
we cannot beat the yellow.
I mean he's a professional player,
so that was kind of over. That's really
a very nice achievement. But man,
I really was at the top and you
could see he played much better,
but our agents got much better too.
So it's a,
and then after the first game, I
said, if we take a single game,
at least we can say we beat a game. I
mean, even if we don't meet the serious,
for me that was a huge relief and I
mean, I remembered it. Hacking them is,
and immediate was,
it was really like these moment for me
will resonate forever as a researcher.
And I mean, as a person and a, yeah,
it's a really great accomplishment and
it was great also to be there with the
team in the room. I don't know if you
saw like, so it was really like, I mean,
from my perspective,
the other interesting thing is
just like watching Kasparov, uh,
watching Mana, uh, was also
interesting because he didn't,
his kind of a a loss of words.
I mean, whenever you lose,
I've done a lot of sports.
You sometimes say excuses,
you look for reasons, right.
And he couldn't really
come up with reasons. Yeah.
I mean, uh, uh, so with the offerings
for protests, you could say it was,
it felt awkward. It wasn't,
but here it was. Yeah, it was,
it was just beaten and it was beautiful
to look at a human being being
superseded by an AI system. And, um,
it's a, it's a beautiful moment for,
for researchers.
So
yeah, for sure. It was, it
was, I mean, probably the
highlight of my career so far,
um, because of its uniqueness
and coolness and I don't know,
I mean it's obviously, as you said, you
can look at papers, citations and so on,
but these,
these really is like a testament of the
whole machine learning approach, um,
and using games to advance technology.
I mean, it's really, it really was.
Everything came together at that
moment that that's really the summary.
Also on the other side,
it's a popularization of AI too
because it's just like traveling to a,
to the moon and so on.
I mean,
this is where a very large community
of people that don't really know AI,
they get to really interact with it.
Very important.
We must, um, you know, writing
papers, hubs, our peers,
researchers to understand
what we're doing.
But I think AI is becoming mature enough
that we must sort of try to explain
what it is and perhaps through games is,
is a,
an abusive way because these
games always had built in AI.
So it may be everyone experience an AI
playing a video game even if they don't
know,
because there's always some scripted
element and some people might even call
that AI already.
Right.
Uh,
so what are other applications of a,
the approaches underlying Alpha
Star that you see happening?
There's a lot of echoes of, he said,
transformer of language modeling. So on,
have you already started thinking where
the breakthroughs in Alpha star get
expanded to other applications?
Right. So I thought that about a few
things for like kind of next month's,
next years.
Um,
the main thing I'm thinking about
actually is what's next as a,
as a kind of a grand challenge because um,
for me like we've seen a tardy
and then there's like the,
the sort of three dimensional walls
that we've seen also like pretty good
performance from these capture the flag
agents that also some people at the mine
and elsewhere are working on.
We've also seen some amazing
results on like for instance,
Dota two which is also a very
complicated game. So for me,
like the main thing I'm thinking about
is what's next in terms of challenge.
So as a researcher I see sort of two
tensions between research and then
applications or areas or
domains where you apply them.
So on the one hand we've done thanks
to the application of starcraft,
he's very hard.
We develop some techniques,
some new research that now
we could look at elsewhere.
Like are there other applications where
we can apply this? And the obvious ones,
absolutely you can think of.
Um,
feeding back to sort of
the community we took from,
which was mostly sequenced modeling
or natural language processing.
So we've developed or an extended things
from the transformer and we use pointer
networks. We combine LSTM and
transformers in interesting ways.
So that's perhaps the kind of lowest
hanging fruit of feeding back to now.
Um, different fields of machine
learning that's not playing video games.
Let me go old school and jump to
the, to Mr Alan Turing. Yeah. Uh,
so the touring test,
no,
it says in natural language
test to compensational tests.
What's your thought of it as
a test for intelligence? Uh,
do you think it is a grand challenge
that's worthy of undertaking?
Maybe if it is, would you reformulate
it or phrase it somehow differently?
Right.
So I,
I really love the touring test because
I also like sequences and language
understanding.
And in fact some of the early work
we did in machine translation,
we tried to apply to apply to
kind of a neuro chat bot. Um,
which obviously would never pass the
Turing test because it was very limited.
But it is a very fascinating,
fascinating idea that you could
really have an AI that would be
indistinguishable from humans in terms
of asking or convert conversing with with
it.
Right.
So I think the test itself seems very
nice and it's kind of well defined
actually like the,
the passing it or not.
I think there's quite a few rules
that feel like pretty simple and, and,
and you know, you could,
you could really like have,
I mean I think they have
these competitions every year,
so the Lug nut prize, but
I don't know if you've seen, eh, I
don't know if you've seen the kind of,
uh,
bots that emerge from that competition.
They're not quite as,
um, what you would, uh,
it feels like that there's weaknesses
with the way touring formulated.
It needs to be,
uh,
that the definition of a genuine rich,
fulfilling human conversation
and needs to be something else.
Like the Alexa Prize,
which I'm not as well familiar with,
has tried to define that more,
I think by saying you have to continue
keeping a conversation for 30 minutes,
something like that. Uh, so basically
forcing the agent not to just fool,
but to have an engaging conversation
kind of thing. Is that, um,
I mean,
is this,
have you thought about this
problem richly? Like has, and if,
if you have in general, how,
how far away are we from?
You worked a lot on language, uh,
understanding language generation,
but the full dialogue, the conversation.
Yeah. You know, just sitting at the bar,
having a couple of beers for an hour,
that kind of conversation.
Have you thought about,
yeah. So I think you'd touched here on
the critical point, which is feasibility,
right? So, so there's, there's a
great sort of essay by humming,
which describes sort of grand challenges
of physics and he argues that,
well, okay, for instance,
teleportation or time travel are
great grand challenges of physics,
but there's no attacks we really don't
know or cannot kind of make any progress.
So that's why most physicists and so on,
they don't work on these in their PhDs
and, and as part of their careers.
So I see the Turing test as I in the food
Turing test as a bit still too early.
Like I am.
I think we're,
especially with the current trend
of deep learning language models,
we've seen some amazing examples,
I think gpt to being the most recent one,
which is very impressive. But
to understand, to fully solve
passing or fooling a human,
to think that you're,
that there's a human on the other side.
I think we're quite far. So as a result,
I don't see myself and I probably would
not recommend people doing a phd on
solving the Turing test because it just
feels it's kind of too early or too hard
of a problem. Yeah. But that said, you
said the exact same thing about starcraft,
but a few years ago, so in the
two demos, so a, I agree. Yeah.
You'll probably also be the person who
passes the Turing test in three years.
I mean, I think, I think that, yeah, so,
so we have the sun record. This is nice.
It's true. It's true. I mean the,
the, it's through that progress.
Sometimes it's a bit unpredictable.
I really wouldn't have
not I even six months ago,
I would not have predicted the level that
we see that these agents can deliver,
um, at the grand master level. But I,
I have worked on language enough and
basically my concern is not that something
happen,
a breakthrough could happen that would
bring us to sobbing or passing the Turing
test is that I just think the
statistical approach to it like this,
he is not, is not going to cut it. So
we, we need, we need to break through,
which is great for the
community. Um, but given that I,
I think there's quite a more uncertainty,
whereas for starcraft,
I knew what the steps would
be to kind of get us there.
I think it was clear that
using the mutation learning
part and then using these
battlenet for agents,
we're going to be key.
And it turned out that this was the
case and a little more was needed,
but not much more for touring test.
I just don't know what the plan
or execution plan would look like.
So that's why I'm,
I myself working on it as a,
as a grand challenge is hard.
But there are quite a few sub challenges
that are related that you could see.
Well,
I mean,
what if you create a great assistant
like Google already has like the Google
Assistant. So can we make it better
and can we make it fully new role?
And so on that I start to believe maybe
we're reaching a point where we should
attempt these challenges.
I like La like this conversation so much
because it echoes very much to start
our conversation.
It's exactly how you approach starcraft.
Let's break it down into small pieces and
solve those and you end up solving the
whole game. Great. But that said, you,
you're behind some of the sort of biggest
pieces of work and deep learning in
the last several years.
So you mentioned some limits.
What do you think of the current limits
of deep learning and how do we overcome
those limits?
So if I had to actually use a single wart
to defined the main challenge in deep
learning is a challenge. That probably
has been the chance for many years.
And he's that of generalization.
So what that means is that okay,
all that we're doing is
feeding functions to data.
And when the data we see ease,
not from the same distribution or even
if they're sometimes that it is very
close to the distribution,
but because of the way we train
it with limited samples, um,
we then get to these states where we just
don't see generalization as much as we
can generalize. And I think adversarial
examples are a clear example of these.
But if you study machine learning
and literature and you know, the,
the reason why svms came very popular
where because they were dealing and they
had some guarantees about generalization,
which is unseen data or
out of distribution or even
within distribution where
you take an image of adding a
bit of noise, these models fail.
So I think really,
I don't see a lot of progress
on generalization in,
in the strong generalization
sense of the word.
I think our newer neural networks,
you can always find design examples
that will make their outputs arbitrary,
which is,
which,
which is not good because we humans will
never be fooled by these kind of images
or manipulation of the image.
And if you look at the mathematics,
you kind of understand this is a bunch
of matrices multiplied together. Um,
there's probably numerics and instability
that you can just find corner cases.
So I think that's really the underlying
topic many times we see when,
um, even even at the grand stage of
like during tests generalization,
I mean you've used, if you start
passing the Turing test, should you,
should it be in English or should it be in
any language? Right? I mean, as a human,
if you could, you could, if you ask
something in a different language,
you actually will go and do some research
and try to translate it and so on.
Should the Turing test
include, include that? Right.
And it's really a difficult problem and
very fascinating and very mysterious
actually. Yeah, absolutely.
But do you think it's, if
you were to try to solve it,
can you not grow the size of data
intelligently in such a way that the
distribution of your training set does
include the entirety of the testing set?
I think is that one path. The other
path is totally new methodologies,
not statistical.
So a path that has worked well and it
worked well even in starcraft and in
machine translation and in languages
scaling up the data and the model.
And that's kind of been maybe the only
single formula that the leap still
delivers today in deep
learning, right? It's,
it's that scale data scale and mother's
care really do more and more of the
things that we thought,
oh,
there's no way it can generalize to these
or if there's no way it can generalize
to that, but I don't think fundamentally
it will be solved with this.
And for instance, I'm really liking, um,
some style or approach that would not
only have neural networks but it would
have programs or some discrete decision
making because there is where I feel
there's a bit more like,
like I mean the example of the best
example I think for understanding disease.
Um,
I also work to be done or like we can
learn an algorithm with a neural network,
right?
So you're given many examples and needs
is going to sort your sort of the input
numbers or something like that.
But really strong generalization is you
give me some numbers or you asked me to
create an algorithm that sorts numbers
and instead of creating a neural net,
which will be fragile because
it's going to go out of range,
at some point you're going to give
you the numbers that are too large,
too small and whatnot.
You just,
if you just create a piece of
code that sorts the numbers,
then you can prove that that will
generalize to absolutely all the possible
input you could give.
So I think that's the problem
comes with some exciting prospects.
I mean scale is a bit more boring,
but it really works.
And then maybe programs and discrete
abstractions are a bit less developed.
But clearly I think they're
quite exciting. In terms
of future for the field,
do you draw any insight,
wisdom from the 80s and expert systems
and symbolic systems of all competing?
Do you ever go back to those sort
of reasoning, that kind of logic?
Do you think that might make a comeback?
You'll have to dust off those books?
Yeah,
I actually love actually I
think more inductive biases.
Um, the problem really is
what are you trying to solve?
If what you're trying to solve is so
important that tried to solve it no matter
what,
then absolutely use rules,
use domain knowledge and then use a
bit of the magic of machine learning to
empower to make the system as the best
system that will detect cancer or,
or, um, you know, or, or the
tech weather patterns. Right.
Or in terms of stock graphics
also was a very big challenge.
So I was definitely happy that if we had
to get take catercorner here and that
it could have been interesting to do.
Um,
and in fact in stacker of wheat we start
thinking about expert systems because
it's a very, you know, you can differ,
I mean people actually build stacker up
boards by thinking about those principle
like state machines and a rule based.
And then you could,
you could think of combining
a bit of a rule based system,
but that has also neuro
networks incorporated to
make it generalize that we'd
better. So absolutely. I mean we should,
we should definitely go back to those
ideas and anything that makes the problem
simpler as long as your problem
is important, that's okay.
And that's research driving a very
important problem. And on the other hand,
if you want to really focus on the
limits of reinforcement learning,
then of course you must try not to look
at a mutation data or to you to look
some like for some rules of the domain
that would help a lot or even feature
engineering, right? So these, these
attention that depending on what you do,
I think both,
both ways are definitely fine and I
would never not do one or the other if
you're, as long as you, what you're doing
is important and needs to be soft. Right?
Right.
Uh, so there's a bunch of
different ideas that, that um,
that you developed that I
really enjoy. So, but one,
one is a translating from
some image captioning trends,
any family shit text.
She's just another just beautiful,
beautiful idea.
I think that um,
resonates throughout your work actually.
So does the underlying nature of
reality being language always somehow.
Uh, so, uh, what's the connection
between images and texts,
the rather the visual world and
a world of language in your view?
Right.
So I think
a piece of research
that's been central to,
I would say even extending into starcraft
is this idea of sequence to sequence
learning. Which what we really
meant by that is that you can,
you can now really input anything
to a neural network as the input x.
And then low neural network will learn
a function f that will take acts as an
input.
And produce any output y and these x
and y's don't need to be like static or
like features like a scene,
like a fixed back doors
or anything like that.
He could be really sequences and now
beyond like data structures, right?
So that paradigm was tested in a very
interesting way when we moved from
translating French to English to
translating an image too. It's caption,
but the beauty,
the beauty of it is that really,
and that's actually how it happened.
I ran,
I change a line of code in this thing
that was doing machine translation.
I and I came the next
day and I saw how it,
like it was producing captions that
seemed like, Oh my God, this is really,
really working. And the
principle is the same, right?
So I think I don't see texts,
vision, speech waveforms
as something different. Um,
eat as long as you basically learn a
function that will vectorize you know,
these into. And then after we vectorize
it, we can then use transformers.
LSTM is whatever the flavor of the month
of the model is a and then as long as
we have enough supervised
data, really, um,
these formula will work
and we'll keep working,
I believe to some extent model of these
generalization issues that I mentioned
before.
So,
but the testers to vectorize sort of
former representation as meaningful and
your intuition now having worked with
all this media is that once you, uh,
are able to form that representation,
you could basically take any things
and you sequence is there, the,
going back to starcraft, is
there limits on the length, uh,
so that we didn't really
touch on the long term aspect.
How did you overcome the whole really
long term aspect of things here?
Is there some tricks or zone?
The main street,
so starcraft,
if you look at absolutely every
frame you might think it's,
it's quite a long game.
So we would have to multiply 22 times,
60 seconds per minute times, maybe at
least 10 minutes per game on average.
So there are quite a few frames,
but the trick really was
too only observed in fact,
which may be seen as a limitation,
but it is also a computational advantage
only observe when you act and then what
the neural network decides is what is the
gap going to be until the next action.
Um, and if you look at most
starcraft games that we have in the,
in the data set that bleeds provided,
it turns out that most
games are actually only,
I mean it is still a long sequence,
but it's maybe like a
thousand to 1500 actions,
which if you start looking at Alice dms,
large Lstm is transformers.
It's not like it's not
that that difficult,
especially if you have
supervised learning.
If you had to do it with reinforcement
learning, the credit assignment problem,
what is it that in this game that made
you, when that will be really difficult.
But thankfully because
of imitation learning,
we didn't kind of have to deal with
these directly. Although if we had to,
we tried it.
And what happened is you just take
all your workers and attack with them.
And that sort of,
it's kind of obvious in retrospect
because you start trying random actions.
One of the actions will be a worker that
goes to the enemy base and because it's
self plate,
it's not going to know how to defend
because he basically doesn't know almost
anything. And eventually what you double
up is this, take our workers and attack.
Um, because the, the, the, the create
assignment issue in our rally is really,
really hard.
I do believe we could do better and
that's maybe a research challenge for the
future. Um, but yeah,
even even in starcraft,
the sequences are maybe a thousand,
which I believe there is within the
realm of what transformers can do.
Yeah.
I guess the difference between starcraft
and go is go and chest stuff starts
happening right away.
Right? So there's not, yeah,
it's pretty easy to self plant,
not easy,
but through selfless as
possible to develop reasonable
strategies as quickly as
opposed to starcraft.
In gold, there's only 400
actions, but one action ease,
what people would call the God action.
That would be if you had
expanded the whole search three,
that's the best action.
If you did mini macs or whatever
algorithm you would do if you had the
computational capacity. But
in starcraft, the 400 is, is,
is miniscule like in 400.
You don't even like you,
you couldn't even click on the
pixels around a unit. Right. So, um,
I think the problem there
is in terms of action,
space size is way harder.
So does surge is impossible.
So there's quite a few challenges
in deed that make these, um,
kind of a step step up in terms
of machine learning for humans,
maybe they playing starcraft is seems more
intuitive because it's, it looks real.
I mean, you know, like get the graphics
and everything moves smoothly. Whereas I,
I don't know how to,
I mean,
go is like a game that I
wouldn't really need to study.
It feels quite complicated,
but for machines kind of
maybe he the reverse. Yes.
Well,
it shows you the gap actually between a
deep learning and however the heck our
brains work.
Uh,
so you developed a lot of really
interesting ideas. It's, it's to just ask,
what's the, what's your process
of developing new ideas?
Do you like brainstorming with others? Do
you like thinking alone? Do you like a,
uh,
like a, was it Ian Goodfellow said he
came up with gans after a few beers.
Uh, right. He thinks beers are
essential for coming up and new ideas.
We had beers to decide to play
another game game of or after a week.
So it's really similar to that story.
Actually explain these in a,
in a deepmind retreat and I said this
is the same as the gun story. I mean,
we were in a bar and we decided
let's play again next weekend.
That's what happened.
I feel like we're doing the wrong
message to young undergrads. Yeah, no,
but in general, like, yeah. Do you like
brainstorming? Do you like thinking alone,
working stuff out?
And so I think,
I think throughout the years also
things change, right? So, um,
initially I was very fortunate to be,
um,
with great minds like Geoff Hinton,
Jeff Dean Elliott, Sutzkever.
I was really fortunate to join
brain at a very good time.
So at that point it ideas,
I was just kind of brainstorming with
my colleagues and learned a lot and keep
learning is actually something you
should never stop doing. Right?
So learning implies reading papers
and also discussing ideas with others.
It's very hard at some point
to not communicate that
being reading a paper from,
from someone or actually this
cussing. Right? So definitely, um,
that communication aspect needs to be
there whether it's written or oral.
Um,
nowadays I'm also trying to be a bit
more strategic about what research to do.
So I was describing a little bit this
sort of tension between research for the
sake of research.
And then you have on the other hand
applications that can drive the research
right?
And honestly,
the formula that has worked best for me
is just find a heart problem and then
try to see how research feeds into it,
how it doesn't fit into it,
and then you must innovate.
So I think machine translation
drove sequence to sequence.
Um,
then maybe like learning algorithms that
had to like communitorial algorithms
led to pointer networks.
Starcraft led to really scaling
up in mutational learning.
And the Alpha Star League. So that's
been a formula that I personally like,
but the other one is also buried.
And I seen it succeed a lot of the
times where you just want to investigate
model based RL as,
as a kind of a research topic.
And then you must then start to
think, well, how are the tests?
How are you going to test these ideas?
Um,
you need to kind of a minimal
environment to try things.
You need to read a lot of papers and
so on. And that's also very fun to do.
And something I've also done quite
a few times, um, both at, at brain,
at the mine and obviously
as, as a PLC. So,
so I think besides the,
the ideas and discussions,
I think it's important also because you
start sort of guiding not only your own
goals but other people's goals,
um, to the next breakthrough.
So you must really kind of
understand these, you know,
feasibility also as we were
discussing before, right?
Weather whether these domain
is ready to be tackled or not.
And you don't want to be too early.
You obviously don't want to be too late.
So it's, it's really interesting. Um,
these are strategic component of research,
which I think as a Grad student I just
had no idea to read papers and discussed
ideas and I think this has been maybe
the major change and I recommend people
kind of feed forward to success how it
looks like and try to back track other
than just kind of looking out at
these looks cool, these looks cool.
And then you do a bit of random work,
which sometimes you stumble upon some
interesting things. But in general it's,
it's also good to plan a
bit. Yeah. Like it, uh,
especially like your approach of
taking a really hard problems,
stepping right in and then being
super skeptical about yeah. Being
a, I mean there, there's
a balance of both, right?
There's a silly optimism and a,
and a critical,
uh, sort of a skepticism
that's good to balance,
which is why it's good to have a team
of people that's that balance that you
don't do that on your own.
You have both mentors that have seen
or you obviously you want to chat and
discuss whether it's the right time.
I mean that means came in 2014 and he
said maybe in a beat we'll do starcraft
and maybe he knew and that's,
and I'm just following his lead,
which is great because he's,
he's brilliant, right? So these,
these things are obviously quite important
that you want to be surrounded by
people who, you know, are diverse.
They have their knowledge,
their there is also important
too. I mean, I, I've,
I've learned a lot from
people who actually have an
idea that I might not think
it's good, but if I give them the space
to try it, I've been proven wrong many,
many times as well. So that's
great. It's, I think it's, um,
your colleagues are more important
than yourself. I think so. Sure. Now,
uh, let's real quick talk about another
impossible problem. Uh, Agi, right?
What do you think it takes to build a
system that's human level intelligence?
We talked a little bit about the Turing
test dark after all these have echoes of
general intelligence.
But if you think about just something
that you would sit back and say, wow,
this is really something that
resembles human level intelligence,
what do you think it takes to build that?
So I find that Agi,
oftentimes it's maybe
not very well defined.
So what I'm trying to then come up with
for myself is what would be a result
look like?
That you would start to believe that you
would have agents or neural nets that
no longer sort of over feet
to a single task, right?
But actually kind of learn
the skill of learning,
so to speak. And that actually is
a field that I am fascinated by,
which is the learning to
learn or metal learning,
which is about no longer
learning about the single domain.
So you can think about the learning
algorithm itself is general, right?
So the same formula we applied
for Alpha star or starcraft,
we can now apply to kind of almost any
video or you could apply to many other
problems and domains. But the algorithm
is what's kind of generalizing,
but the neural network,
the weights,
those weights are useless even
to play another race. Right?
I train a network to play very
well at products versus products.
I need to throw away those weights.
If I want to play now Taryn versus Taryn,
I would need to retrain and Edward
from scratch we'd the same algorithm.
That's beautiful but the network itself
will not be useful. So I think when I,
if I see an approach that can absorb or
start solving new problems without the
need to kind of restart the process,
I think that to me would be a nice
way to define some form of Agi.
Again,
either know the grandiose like age,
I mean he should during test we saw
before Agi. I mean I don't know. I think,
I think concretely I would like to see
clearly that metal learning happen.
Meaning there there is and architecture
or network that as it sees new,
new problem or new data it solves it
and to make it kind of a benchmark,
each should solve it at the same
speed that we do solve new problems.
When I define your new object and
you have to recognize it. When I,
when you start playing a new game,
you played all the time, the games,
but now you play a new Atari game. Well
you, you're going to be pretty quickly,
pretty good at the game.
So that's perhaps what,
what's the domain and what's the
exact benchmark is a bit difficult.
I think as a community we might
need to do some work to define it,
but I think this first step I could
see it happen relatively soon,
but then the whole,
what Agi means and so on,
I am a bit more confused about what
I think people mean different things.
There's an emotional,
psychological level that, um,
like even the Turing test passing the
Turing test is something that we just pass
judgment on as human beings. What it
means to be, you know, as a, as a,
as a dog a is an s an AGI system.
Yeah.
Like what level? What does it mean? Uh,
right? Yeah. What does, what does it mean?
But I liked the generalization,
and maybe as a community would converge
towards a group of domains that are
sufficiently far away.
There'll be really damn impressive
if Fossa able to generalize some,
perhaps not as close as protests.
And Zurg was like, yeah,
could be a good stuff.
And then the really good stuff,
but then then like could from starcraft
two Wikipedia. Yeah. And back. Yeah.
That kind of thing. And that, that
feels also quite hard and far. But
I think this, as long as
you put a benchmark out, as
we discovered for instance,
with image net,
then tremendous progress can be had.
So I think maybe there's
a lack of benchmark,
but I'm sure we'll find one
and the community, we'll,
we'll then work towards that.
MMM.
And then beyond what Agi
might mean or would imply,
I really am hopeful to see basically
machine learning or AI just scaling up and
helping people that might not have the
resources to hire an assistant or that,
uh, they might not even know what the
weather is like, but you know, so,
so I think there's, in terms of the
impact, the positive impact of Ai,
I think that's maybe what we
should also not lose focus, right?
The research community building edgy. I
mean, that's a real nice goal, but a man,
I think the way that deep mind puts it is,
and then use it to solve everything else.
Right? So I think we should penalize.
Yeah.
We shouldn't forget of all the,
all the positive things that are actually
coming out of AI already and they're
going to be coming out. Right. But that,
and then, no, let me ask, uh,
relative to the popular perception,
do you have any worry about
the existential threat of
artificial intelligence in
the near or far future
that some people have?
I think I'm in the near future. I'm, I'm
skeptical, so I'm hope I'm not wrong.
But I'm, um, I'm not concerned,
but I appreciate efforts,
ongoing efforts and even
like whole research field
on AI safety emerging and in
conferences and so on. I think
that's great. Um, in the long term,
I really hope we just can't simply have
the benefits outweigh the potential
dangers. I am hopeful for that. Um,
but also we must remain vigilant to
kind of monitor and assess whether the
tradeoffs are, are there and, and,
and we have, you know, enough,
I'm also lead time to prevent or
to redirect our efforts if need be.
Right. So, um, but I'm, I'm quite,
I'm quite optimistic about the technology
and definitely more fearful of other
threats in terms of planetary
level, um, at, at this point.
But obviously that's the one
I kind of have more power on.
So clearly I do start thinking more
and more about these and it's kind of,
it's grown in me actually to,
to start reading more about AI safety,
which is a fuel that so far I have
not really contributed to, but maybe
there's something to be done there as
well. I think it's really important.
You know, I, I talk
about this a few folks,
but it's important to ask you and shove
it in your head because you're at the
leading edge of actually, uh, what
people are excited about and AI,
I mean the work with Alpha star it,
it's arguably at the very cutting edge
of the kind of thing that people are
afraid of.
And so you speaking to that fact and uh,
that we're actually quite far away to
the kind of thing that people might be
afraid of, but it's still worthwhile
to think about in a salsa.
Good that you're, uh, the,
you're not as worried and
you're also open to us.
Yeah, I mean there's two aspects.
I mean me not being worried,
but obviously we should prepare
for four, four, eight rides for,
for like, for, for things that could go
wrong. Misuse of the technologies as,
as with any technology is,
right. So I think there's,
there's always trade offs and I,
as a society,
we've kind of solved these to
some extent with in the past.
So I'm hoping that by having
the researchers and the
whole community brainstorm
and come up with interesting solutions
to the new things that will happen in the
future,
that we can still also push the research
to the avenue that I think is kind of
the greatest avenue, which is to
understand intelligence, right?
How are we doing what we're
doing? Um, and you know,
obviously from a scientific standpoint
that is kind of the drive my personal
driver or all the time I spend
doing what I'm doing. Really.
Where do you see the deep
learning as a field heading?
What do you think the next
big, big breakthrough? My B.
So I think deep learning,
I discuss a little of these before.
Deep learning has to be combined with
some form of democratization programs,
indices.
I think that's kind of as a researching
itself is an interesting topic to expand
and start doing more research.
Uh,
and then as kind of what we'll deep
learning and able to do in the future.
I don't think that's going to be
what's going to happen this year,
but also this idea of starting not to
throw away all the ways that this idea of
learning to learn and really having,
um,
these agents not having to
restart their weights. And you,
you can have an agent that is kind of
solving or classifying images on image net
but also generating speech if you
ask it to generate some speech. And,
and it should really be kind
of almost the same network,
but my boat, none. That might
not be a neural network.
It might be a neural network with a
optimization algorithm attached to it.
But I think this idea of generalization
to new task is something that we first
must defined good benchmarks, but then,
uh, I think that's going to be exciting.
And I'm not sure how close we are,
but I think there's,
if you have a very limited domain,
um,
I think we can start doing some progress
and more much like how we did a lot of
programs in computer vision,
we should start thinking,
am I real like a talk that I gave that
[inaudible] cave at ICML a few years ago,
which is these trained tests paradigm
should be broken. We, you know,
we should stop thinking about
a training test at, at, sorry,
a training set and a test set
and these are closed, you know,
things that are untouchable.
I think we should go beyond these.
And in metal learning we call these the
metta training set and the metatarsal,
which is really thinking about,
if I know about image net,
why would that network not
work on [inaudible], which
is a much simpler problem.
But right now it really doesn't it, you
know, but it, it just feels wrong. Right?
So I think that's kind
of the, there's the, uh,
on the application or the benchmark sites,
we probably see quite a few more interest
and progress and hopefully people
defining new and exciting
challenge is really,
do you have any hope or interest and
knowledge graphs within this context?
So this is kind of totally,
yeah. Constructing Gra.
So going back now, graphs,
yeah,
well neural networks and graphs,
but I mean a different kind of
knowledge graph. Uh, uh, sort of, uh,
like semantic grass or there's concepts.
Yeah. So I think, I think the,
um, the idea of graphs is,
is, so I've been quite
interested in sequences first
and then more interesting or
different data structures like graphs.
And I've studied graph neural networks,
um, in the last three years or so. I, uh,
I found these models just very
interesting from like deep learning sites
standpoint. Um, but then
how, how, what do we want,
why do we want these models are,
and why would we use them?
What's the application? What's kind of
the killer application of graphs? Right,
right.
And perhaps if we could extract a
knowledge graph from Wiki automatically,
that would be interesting because then
these graphs have these very interesting
structure that also is a bit more
comfortable with this idea of programs and
deep learning, kind of working together,
the jumping neighborhoods and so on.
You could imagine defining some primitives
to, to go around and graphs. Right.
So I think I really liked the idea of
a knowledge graph and in fact when we,
we started or you know, as part of the
research we did for starcraft, I thought,
wouldn't it be cool to give
the graph of all the Prereq?
There's like there's all these buildings
that depend on each other and you need
that, have prerequisites
of being billed by that.
And so this is information that
the network can learn an extract,
but it would have been great to see,
um,
or to think of really starcraft as a
giant graph that even also as the game
evolves, you just kind of started taking
branches and so on. And we try, we, we,
the bit of research on these,
nothing too relevant. Um, but I,
I really liked the idea
and it has elements that are,
which something you also worked
with in terms of visualizing,
you'll network says elements of
having human interpretable, uh,
being able to generate
knowledge representations
that are human interpretable
that maybe human experts can then
tweak or at least understand the,
so there's a lot of interesting
aspect there. And for me personally,
I'm just a huge fan of Wikipedia
and, and it's a shame that, uh,
our neural networks aren't
taking advantage of all the
structured knowledge and
that's on the web. What's next for,
uh, for you, what's next for deep mind?
What are you excited about?
What a for Alpha Star.
Yeah,
so I think the obvious next steps
would be too apply Alpha star too.
Other races.
I mean that's sort of shows
that the algorithm works
because we wouldn't want to
have created by mistake something in the
architecture that happens to work for
protests but not for other races.
Right.
So Asbury effication I think that's an
obvious next step that we are working on.
And then I would like to see,
so agents and players can specialize on
different skillsets that allow them to
be very good.
I think we've seen Alpha
start understanding very
well when to take battles and
when to not to do that.
Do that.
Also very good at micro management
and moving the units around and so on.
And also very good at producing nonstop
and trading of economy with building
units.
But I have not perhaps seen as much as
I would like this idea of the poker idea
that you mentioned.
Right.
I'm not sure it's stacked graph or
Alpha star rather has developed a deep
understanding of what the opponent is
doing and reacting to that and sort of
trying to to, to treat the player to
do something else or that, you know,
so these kinds of reasoning
I would like to see more.
So I think purely from a
research standpoint, um,
there's perhaps also quite a few,
a few things to be done there in
the domain of starcraft. Yeah.
In the domain of games. I've seen
some interesting work in sort of a,
and even auctions
manipulating other players.
So forming a bleed state and just
messing with people. So theory of mind.
Yep. So it's a fascinating,
exactly. Theory of mine on
stock, or if he's kind of,
they're really made for each other.
So that will be very exciting to see
those techniques applied to starcraft or
perhaps starcraft driving new
techniques. Right. As as, as I said,
this is always the tension
between the two. Well, oil,
thank you so much for talking today.
Awesome. It was great to be here. Thanks.